je l'entendais khalij et
sont dans la boîte de nuit ils sont
découragé de l'activité mais gagnant
l'agrobusiness
la farine la famille audi nous boulevard
langage
mais la solution est faussement trouver
partout comme je me suis dit peut-être
ce n'est pas le moins qu il faut s moi
un ça va
je suis loin des caméras loin de la
notre gueule je laisse le mal était fier
parce que ça ne me fait rien de mal à un
aller en ville il y avait un monsieur
ça c'est un système il n'y apas
7ème des travailleurs au liban ni les
de moi maintenant c'est moi qui lui
un vus
orienté dans ce département sciences du
capitale guinéenne à 135 km de la
même je mérite de me lancer dans cette
moment un monsieur m'a croisé en ville
tenait une boutique il avait de
fournissait des paquets d'eau arrivent à
humiliation
peut-être c'est la relation qui peut
racines qu'elle ait l'air mais pour
ses calculs effet l'étude du projet pour
activité
langage à la faculté langues et lettres
ap je le prendrais 6 2 face à la réalité
c'était le propriétaire d'une entreprise
capitale guinéenne dans une ville
nous maintenant il fallait maintenant
voici les questions que je me posais je
vous accorder un poste où soit vous
travailler
compléter la base c'est là bas qu'ils
parce qu'ils n'ont pas récupéré du
langage me renvoie quelque chose
c'est les autres tu va me remplacer au
de vente d'eau qui avait une petite
dénommée kindia appelé par les natifs de
tapez une campagne pour un politicien
venaient des comptes et
planter exemple un état d'ananas il me
peut-être pour les langues
me suis dit s'ils avaient tous saisine
poulet dans le vent maintenant c'était
hautois et se sont accaparés de cela
il s'amuse on sait faire toi nous
une fois au président il vous nomme
industrie qui produisait devant ça c'est
aux glaces est là pour aller revendre
devenu son fournissent un
faut 75 millions francs guinéens un
cette ville gagna
comme le connaissant le système non je
qui entreprend le cv de l'immigration
donc tu resté inerte c'est la rupture et
enliser dans les villes le couple qui
ses réservoirs et m'ont dit tu veux
droit dont il faut parler des sergents
en boîte donc il m'a consulté je ne sais
donc
beaucoup
me suis dit il faut se concentrer à
étudiant même si d'ici là depuis qu'il a
quand tu veux faire non javi restons ici
un regain
donc je suis là pour vous raconter mon
lui conférait même pas la langue qui
pour aller en occident c'est qu'ils
tentent d'y accéder le sort nous étions
pas si ça à travers le voisin qui sert
étudier peut-être demain on pourrait
de l'ami des choses on me convoque et
que ce pays 6 pds il pensait dans la
parlait deuxièmement je ne connaissais
nombreux à être orientée dans ce
veulent aller à la capitale pour ce
pour lancer mon cousin
ainsi à propos de moi même et ses tracas
d'abord donc se rendre à l'intérêt je me
parcours
relever le défi mais au cours au moment
maintenant la gendarmerie s'est passé
département
la malade il me dit me donna une petite
un parcours plein de difficultés
personne d'arriver donc de vous voir
faire de nos équipes et de grands
le premier jour à l'université à se
ça me pose est qui s'est imposé un
capitale il faut être humble au garde à
suis senti j'ai enlevé ma chemise et que
quoi vous attendez vous en servez pas de
ce que je faisais la licence 1 je me
passent ainsi de suite ceci dit comme
un pack ou au plein d'enseignements
vous venez de me suis dit c'est un
fantôme qui ne verra jamais
poser la question c'est quel département
vous à mazet doit nous amener le gardien
4 que d'aller lui rendre visite dans le
je portais pour aller à l'université
j'ai décidé de rester dans la campagne
puis bien brailler zem 6 septembre et
paris lundi vers
suis dit après avoir fini étudié qu'est
mensonge il faut finir avec ces super
ça qu'est-ce que nous nous serrions
regard de la cat je les appelais sur
devrait être un an seulement que je
doux même si je parle de la région nous
être un village ainsi d'ici j'ai décidé
la mi-août
demain et
français restés dans le bus la slovénie
ce que je ferai dans la vie donc j'ai
osé penser et puis je me suis dit
donc je me suis dis rien su de suite
l'enchère croiser une belle femme qui
avoir
maintenant j'ai décidé d'arbres à deux
vous combien le système phrase mal ça
j'ai apporté ma ténu avec une culotte
aidé à mon avis je trime été rendue
quelqu'un est devenu elle sera ouverte
devrai
veut me prendre comme un agent
d'être un village mais il faut exercer
d'abord je connais ma ville je connais
décidé de trouver une solution face à
partager avec mes amis ac oui si tu veut
semaines immigration qui n'a jamais lu
commercial de lavande ou de cette
publique au début du set jusque-là zf
jovi se serait tourné un commentaire
l'activité de ces villageois la cie
au ministre du pays est une personne
m'a mis à penser ça m'a renvoyé partout
ce village il faut initier une activité
entreprise moi mon objectif c'était quoi
mon ambition mais nomination nécessité
comme ça comme un jeu elle a dit non
demain c'est qu'ils se font appeler des
unique du passif entre mais non rien
ces problèmes
seule à
ainsi pas là mais c'est un grand jour
le matin c'est de venir à l'entreprise
se lancer dans l'entrepreneuriat
capitalistes de grands politiciens de
posséder sa montée du
mais ça m'a fallu du temps passé des
celle ci c'est une entreprise fait
qui peut m'apporter de la en coûte un
d'un tamis c'est d'inverser le biais
nous allons faire embarquer laissé dans
pour moi aujourd'hui
gazon ci se retourne à kindia que moi
vouloir
sortir marque l'a16 et la montre
de remercier sûr mais c'est un ppri du
d'achats jacky g20 à venir à bout c'est
je vous assure
nuits blanches sans nommer partager le
service que gérant et puis je gagne en
collaboration des
le camion pour aller les vendre a dit
d'oublier ils ont depuis cette
et se sont mis à rigoler est loin d'
plus donc je lançais une équipe de vente
aussi je les présente mon corps dit
personnalités ils ont laissé les modèles
butin à dos mil à 1,4 à penser qu
l'entrepreneuriat c'est un monde inconnu
vous qui depuis ce que commencer mais
dieu merci j'ai gagné sept ans est assis
plantation
qu'ils consomment ça pour dire qu'il
talent caché à l'intérieur du pays qu'on
illégale est devenu fou
affi du thé varela civile a dit didier
maintenant nous sommes en couple c'est
adriano mais peut-être à tout moment je
peut parler cécile sans toucher à ce
c'est comme si on décide de se rendre
la glace était en tête maintenant c'est
innovants ou merveilleux qui nous met
appelle monsieur aboubacar sidiki traoré
et lorsque
dalleau semblerait sous moi désormais
produit là donc il faut produit de la
un problème devient maintenant le rwanda
me disais qu'est ce que je dois faire
pourquoi le saas est là pour les faire
un des chefs de département c'est zoug
dans un pays où on n'a jamais mis les
vous êtes une entreprise vous avez un
n'oubliez pas pourquoi moi j'ai vendu
dans le pays et vous commencez à
embarquer dans le camion par le ca 10
visé ou d'un coup sûr à la tête
nana et de banane
quel est ce service que je vais
fait aussi des dettes a reçu deux
produit à vendre
pieds
il m'a passé un conseil je n'oublierai
l'eau glacée c'est parce que j'avais un
commence ça commence à voir si
comme ça cette idée m'est venue
soutiens venus de loin à pomas est
un pays
peut-être vous n'avez pas d agent
du parti
présenter
objectif à réaliser il me faut avoir une
jamais de ma vie il me dit ceci ramadân
là où on ne connaît pas les réalités une
aux autres peut-être qu'ils vont admirer
commercial à l'intérêt qui ne veut pas
donc je me suis lancé dans la production
le monsieur là qui était mon fournisseur
maintenant reconnu comme on dit quand ça
plantation
sacrifie qu'un sud stable le vert ou
éliminer la divine et un sixième a donné
écoute ceux ci il n'y a pas ce
aller vivre dans le village ou dans la
fois descendu de l'aéroport ou bien dans
ça il faut parce que cela me coûterait
dans mes amis je me suis mis à penser
de la nana et de balan mais comment
noir moi qui devrait être la solution
département pour être un minus ou un
campagne où le village or nous sommes là
qui m'est donnée aux 109 ans de la place
commence à aller mal tout le monde sait
une cave voiture
ça vous chante maintenant servir ou sa
ainsi de suite
président dans la vie il m'a dit un
mettre maintenant place aux pauses et
vous faire vous faire sortir mon père
75 millions francs guinéens maintenant
qu'est-ce que vous attend où se trouve
nous nous allons vous aider à écouler
ce jusqu'au à vous maintenant 5 ans
était un salaire plus que ce n 'est pas
nourriture maintenant mon ambition c'est
j'ai parlé - je n'avais pas accès à la
j'avais regardé autour de moi je suis
ses produits c'est comme ça qu'ils aient
votre destination
c'est calculé 7,75 millions laser est
mathématicien peut-être un président un
bailey rae sont dit
entre nantes et qui vivent dans les
si c'était 6000 francs mais là où je
débuté passé l'a d'abord j'ai deux buts
donc pour vous parler de mon pack où je
revoir chez tous ceux de fer la guinée
dans une préfecture d'abord le nom de
banque même un compte bancaire ne tenait
que tu me alain rousset était mort au
divisé en 365 jours
agriculteur peut être un président celui
mandats et montrera numérique paisible
et en revendre ce que l'on appelle au
est un modèle seat algérie où le mot
travaillais là bas le patron nous a
pas je savais pas pourquoi mon appel un
scène que fait-il on dit on l'appelle
vous savez une année compte 365 jours
mouloudia mais je ne parvenais pas à
suis né à kindia
qui n'a jamais été à l'école peut
glace et
donné de la bande à 5000 francs le
come back je me suis fait avoir les
résume à ces deux pays en matière de
pour l'attribuer un adjectif
ramasser le pouvoir au bord de la route
dans une préfecture
bouger toutes les dettes il n'y avait
c'était moi une source de problèmes
hors glace et je mettais la glace sur ma
bien donc maintenant c'est 365 joue dû
lendemain suis allé le retrouver je la
qualificatif qu'on dit la cité des
conditions de l'arrêt du banal c'est mon
donc j'ai compris le système
choses à penser mais comme j'ai trouvé
graves à la provocation play speedy
dis maintenant neuf appelé à céder un
plus de personnes mais venez vous avec
tête pas où je pouvais a encaissé dix
quand les parents n'ont pas assez de
ambition
viser 75 millions diviser par 365
agrumes donc je me suis dit je suis de
package à 6000 femmes mais plutôt à
j'ai compris le cas donc j'ai accepté
sebah donc de rester d'atari de
d'abord la première solution c'est à
moyens
kindia c'est kim gars qui m'a vu naître
mille 15000 francs comme intérêt c'est
celle qui dit comment tu peux me fait
comme tous les autres enfants qui sont
avec la détermination
quoi il faut se lancer quel s pour dit
ça me ferait pas jouer il me faut
et grandir
mais du temps je l'expliqué mon cas et
l'immigration qu'elle ne se met pas la
débuté mollo mollo sa 12 en caisse avec
pourquoi ne pas transformer la ressource
je me suis même désigné à être une
nés dans les campagnes mon papa est un
encaisser deux cent cinq mille francs
qu'il faut présenter au public
main qui mène vers le sud avant tout
la promotion qu'égérie cet ancien de
un mélange du sud il y avait certes un
responsable de ce département et être
qui se trouve sur 7
guinéens maintenant il faut tout faire
simple étalagiste ses danseurs que siné
peut-être le public
cette promotion même s'il n'ya pas un
dans les pays africains étaient en route
à une chose qui serait utile non
ami à l'université qui me demandait de
pour gagner pas ou deux cent cinq mille
porteur du message pour que mes amis les
pour une sortie vous donner la mesure
contrat de travail rien du tout mais
le public va apprécier beaucoup
mais quelles que soient les souffrances
francs guinéens donc c'est ce qui m'a
me
uns ou aux autres nouvelles cendres le
était fier de cette promotion parce que
était
seulement pour la cité pour la guinée
disais ça qu'au moment où on te voit
peut-être que le public va demander des
poussé à rebours glacée sur sa la
l'ami de tout ce qui ne va pas mais
et la difficulté que mon papa traversée
c'est français en pas donc on leur fait
département reste conçu le courant
tout manger un bon plat comment tu fais
pour le continent et pour le monde
services quand je me suis dit quand j'ai
manière j'ai continué à le vente cela
c'était une obligation pour 4 à celui
semble donc je me suis assignées cette
il s'est toujours à bâtir mon éducation
pour parvenir à cela
entier me suis dit avec moncozet portant
débarquer vingt paquets là bas il m'a
aucun de mes amis étudiants ne
trouvé ce cas d'abord il faut me lancer
des armes et des décisions
mission et puis j'ai réussi
raconté là aujourd'hui et hélas et en
elle a dit oui moi en ce moment je
dans l'agout business le deuxième point
m'accompagne et puis parfois si c'était
il m'envoya dans une école et quels que
une lutte contre la famine je pourrais
ben
d'intérêt mais la ville
c'est comment trouver maintenant les
paca c'est multi marie baudoin a gagné à
dans la salle on me dit là le cervelas
donc j'ai compris ce qui m'attendait je
soient les obstacles et en douterait pas
travaille dans une grande entreprise qui
attribué emplissent au combat mondial je
5 donc je la dis je ne suis pas
moins ou lancer cette activité parce que
a investi beaucoup de pays pour 12
on me disait tu fous là dit corby la
toi qui as une entreprise via
abandonné j'ai continué mes études
me suis dit c'est qu'ils ont fait la
brigades de difficultés souvent alain
sa demande de lada il faut rémunérer le
gestion ou je ne sais pas aimer
famille a été super et hyper il aime la
pourrais attribuer un plus au
l'entreprise
primaires secondaires jusqu'à
informatique et cousines quoi après les
za ils ne voient même règle à ses envies
travail à moi seul je ne peux pas faire
sans qu ils m'appellent en invité par
développement de ma cité de mon pays de
l'université c'est dans 16 écoles
ce travail il faut la paix je me suis
epide ils sont dans les quartiers ils
publiques mais comment je portais
nous montrer d'après le coût en mana
mon continent donc je me suis lancé dans
mis à penser deux villes
confiance moi tout dans cette école
l'agglo business
wap son suivi ces prélats transport pour
parce que pendant les vacances si on se
maintenant comment lancé dans
croisait avec des amis qu'ils étudiaient
dans ces écoles privées même si au cours
de l'essence je comprenais pas la
différence entre nous la formation
qu'ils avaient acquise de l'autre côté
la formation qu'ils en avaient parfois
la mienne la dépasse donc ainsi dit
peut-être et c'est un système qu'ils ont
voulu nous et quelques peut-être est-ce
un manque de suivi ou de conseils et
ainsi de suite donc continuer sur ce pas
depuis qu'elles ont obtenu mon
baccalauréat
est constaté dans ma cité dans ma
préfecture la préfète il était vite de
ses unes de ses bras valides ça qu'elle
voulait se faire la place à la capitale
si on veut être un grand homme si on
veut être un grand politicien ou si on
veut être un gars de l'entrepreneur il
faut forcément aller à la capitale mais
moi je me suis dit qu'est ce qui
occasionne cela il faut que cela cesse
quand même mis à penser d'abord là pour
faire mon orientation donc sous le coup
des causes et pour l'université de
kindia parce que je me suis dit cette
ville m'a vu naître et grandir
cette ville m'a tout donné donc je dois
rembourser à cette ville il faut que moi
aussi je fasse moins de l'université à
kindia rester ce soir si tous les autres
ont fui pour la capitale donc moi il
faut rester c'est mois étudiés là-bas
peut-être pouvoir si je pouvais
m'imposer comme il s'impose à sont
fournis à dans les grandes universités
de la capitale voit l'occident moi aussi
je me suis dit il faut si demain on
parlerait d'un granum il faut qu'on dit
qu'ils viennent de l'université de
kindia et puis c'est un natif de cagnes
ah c'était ça mon ambition c'était ça
mon autre étude
donc mais sur le coup avec le système
ils m'ont orienté dans un département
intitulé c'était ma première fois dans
tag non de ce département sciences du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]